Material design says that motion
design can effectively guide
the user's attention in ways
that both inform and delight.
Use motion to smoothly transport
users between navigational contexts.
Explain changes in the arrangement
of elements on a screen.
And reinforce element hierarchy.
We aren't really doing that yet.
But we can add something that does,
a shared element transition.
When we talk about shared elements,
we're really talking about Android
views that contain content that is
shared between two different activities.
We animate the transition between
the activities by moving and
scaling the element into place,
which draws the eye to the element and
creates continuity between
the two activities.
It's relatively easy to add a shared
element to the transition we've
already created.
We first need to tell Android which
views in both activities are paired up.
We start by adding a transition name
to the view in the destination layout.
We'll also want to add a transition
name to any view that we're
transitioning from.
So that the system can find it again in
case it has to tear down the activity,
thanks to rotating the device or
some other hardware change.
If the shared view is filled out
when the activity is first created,
that's all we'd have to do.
However, many activities do
things like create a fragment and
then need to go to the database
to fetch the shared element.
Both of which typically involve
asynchronous tasks, and
we are using best Android practices.
We also want to wait for
any layout to be complete.
Fortunately there's a solution for that.
We can ask Android to wait
before beginning the transition
using supportPostponeEnterTransition.
And tell it we're ready by using
supportStartPostponedEnterTransition.
We have to a bit careful here
about how long we postpone things,
as we've pretty much stopped
the world in motion when we do this.
I.e., going out to the network while
we postpone things isn't going to
work well.
Since I try very hard to keep
display-related logic in layouts,
I'm going to create an attribute to
enable postponing the enter transition
in forecast fragment.
I then read the attribute
in the onInflate method.
For the detail fragment,
I'll add a flag as an argument and
read it during the onCreateView method.